what's up guys and welcome back to the
so for the first time ever Jen and
Jillian podcast has not one but two
guests on the podcast this week we have
Chris Mel burger and Cher ah thank you
guys for joining us today
yes really excited that you guys are
here thank you for having thank you so
much I feel like we've talked about you
guys coming on a lot and then you
finally are intense we're like yeah
let's do it
like for real yeah that's exciting okay
and now we're here in ru so you guys are
visiting you live in New Jersey yes
Sparta Sparta yes Barney I would call
smart yes sweet name right when 300 came
out we we all went to the movie theater
and the part were like this is spot the
whole theater it was just like I did it
yeah as you guys do yeah it was about
your town no no - Daria was a lot of
arrows people die as yeah yeah there is
yeah well for those of you guys who
don't know for whatever weird reason who
these guys are what even are you even
wasn't even doing there no they make
really funny vines amongst other things
that they do Shanna's photography Chris
does a bunch of other stuff he does hat
he's wearing and this shirt I'm wearing
is his brand called Neetu which is very
popular yes well actually you do well
they honest we were a lot of knee to
knee treat stuff another hit that guy
Chris is company and he made that well
you don't feel like doing your hair in
the wind you put a hat it's true dude
that's what we use on YouTube be nice
for when you're not feeling it dude
exactly yeah so how are you guys
enjoying LA cuz you're you you've like a
decent-sized trip hugger
yeah we've kind of been here for what
suggest yeah and then we have like a
week left - yeah I mean that's nice
hey yeah I just don't play your flight
back okay I haven't done it yet well
just like sleeping people's couches huh
yeah we got a couch later we also have a
love sack and what's your costume later
than right mm elderscrolls
so late in the morning is there an elder
scrolls rehab I can go to know I don't
literally destroying with it how are you
uh how far unit I think I'm about five
percent done that's what terrifies me
because there's been hours 80 hours in
tone into that came 89 how do they do
that
that's insane yeah they spent I mean how
many people work on a game like that to
make that the logistics of creating that
game actually means ID make you want to
throw up but not while I'm playing um so
you guys uh when did you guys meet yeah
well well that's great well the UH we
met through vine tell us actually okay
yeah men on that second video
application okay so who saw who's fine
or how did that work
I can uh you gonna tell me okay so um a
guy who I followed two years ago I so
follow him he actually now works at vine
it's pretty cool he's editor there his
name is Jason manty and I was on his
page one day randomly sometimes I'll
check people's likes cuz you can see
what like what they're liking yeah Jenna
does that's it huh what's this guy hey
what's he liking and then we had saw my
cover like distorted bull because you
can find like maybe like new Viners are
just new things that are funny or cool
or interesting and so I want his page
and I was like huh
he liked a few this girl's videos I was
like this girl's pretty insane what the
heck is still down she's playing with
roadkill and she isn't dancing like on
top of whatever and she's laying up in
boss and she's singing his little weird
songs about chicken
chickens and stuff and so I was like
okay I'm gonna I think I stayed up like
for an hour and a half watching her
videos and
I think I did and then I think you
followed me in the morning huh and then
followed me on Twitter and tweeted at me
and you really what's up and then I
treated you back and then I was like not
much and then we just started DMing and
we actually found recently found who
standing in who's first she seated she's
in the mind is um and we actually found
the original DMS recently that's also
oddly she cried yeah I was like yeah oh
yeah how long was that yeah and and did
you guys live near each other not in two
hours we live two hours apart right now
yeah yeah you do
it's a commute I didn't know that yeah
we don't live in York so yeah wait well
maybe I'm still in Jersey she was an
upstate New York we're in upstate New
York
well two counties above the city it's
not like yes yeah okay so I hear ups in
here yeah i stacked the sake of the town
of the city it's really true to admit
that's interesting I didn't know that
yeah and then we I was like eh we should
like collab because what people do on
internet yeah and you really just wanted
to hang out who actually I know
seriously like how you're weird let's
collab let's make videos cuz people ever
she was like blowing up everyone's like
yo this girl's crazy she's weird what
the heck what is this and I was like yo
she's kind of close to me be funny to
like incorporate some comedy with some
weird stuff yeah and so we actually
ended up meeting up in a little town
called Poughkeepsie in New York which is
like PMC and we went to because that's
where I used to go to college so I was
gonna be there for a long that weekend
and I assumed she was close which was
like and they are about it was worth it
yeah uh-huh and so we met at an
abandoned insane asylum
what yeah cuz I was like you're weird
you might like this yeah such a great
meeting spot yeah I was gonna die
honestly I know it was yeah was it it
he's gonna kill you yeah yeah I thought
he was gonna come and our first vines
that we made they're like the first we
ever met our vines I made er still like
on our pages and it's like you could
literally see really hangin out like
making like pretty pretty terrible vines
it's cool really cool first person I
ever met ever so cool okay so that's
adorable
I don't want to clear something up you
kept calling her weird and her weird
vines ha
you make vines sometimes you have rats
yeah and sometimes you incorporate dead
animals in nearby yeah and that
obviously right away can turn people off
because they're like oh it's a dead
thing what is this you know but you have
an interesting philosophy because you
told me your thoughts on this boy and
why you have a fascination with it and I
think it's really cool I think Jenna
does too I did do you want any of
YouTube channel right yeah but you're
dead things on your YouTube channel
yeah I had like a whole um first thing
about it because like I mean I get a lot
of crap for it
good thing they're like alien you're
like a Marian and like a list of it's
like no I actually love animals they are
like my life but I also love them with
it when they're dead too yeah I don't
kill them I don't personally kill them
like I can't do that I'll help like my
dad like dude the turkeys and stuff when
we have them but um I can't physically
do it I just can't I feel too bad but um
I don't know I just like admire I Meyer
them and I think that even when I mean
they're dead or whatever you could still
like preserve them and like I still have
them like around and you do learn a lot
about animals like when you start like
dissecting them and stuff like it's not
so Robbie no but like no one ever said
that yeah it's like it should be really
morbid but we don't see her with her
dead animals it's like the sweetest
thing in the whole world cuz she like
really really loves is ridiculous is Lee
adorable I like see my like oh it's so
cute cuz like it's tattling but it's so
like like why would you stop
appreciating
right and she found on a dead like
little gecko or lizard and she was like
all the blue they need attention to yeah
like yeah I understand like the burial
aspect of like burying your animals cuz
like I don't ever people do that but
like I don't want to want to do that so
like it's such a waste
like I wanna keep it yeah I want to look
at all time have you ever gotten sick
from playing with dead animals no well
you're probably safe you're probably not
eating right after you yeah I used to do
a lot as a kid I would just put is to
put bugs and stuff in my pockets and I'm
gonna eat bugs and let anything that was
like an animal I wanted to boomba and my
mom is like you'll get sick like don't
do that and I've never gotten sick
either yeah I'm wondering yes you got
sick yeah yeah I think this is a lie no
getting sick from deer yeah that seems
like a myth okay speaking of your hands
animals just don't eat up don't but
maybe don't eat it and if you do we
didn't tell you to do it well let's just
start just a theory
speaking of your rats your pet rats how
many of you have three three who's
watching them right now and how much are
they getting yeah my brother he's 12 I
think is like oh um can can you pay me
two dollars a week to watch your rats
like okay please send me pictures of
them and they're like horrible and
blurry to be always the weird
I'm like okay okay I'm more than that
that's that's too much more than he
would have been made
they should have low-balled him $1 Lee
yeah I was like okay I'll pay that way
thank you okay so and then back to
needed you started that how long 2008
right yeah so 2008 was kind of when the
like the name came to be me my buddy was
hanging out John yeah you met John yeah
I couldn't meet him this week I met him
with you might you might meet him from
my birthday oh okay yeah well um but
yeah so Jonah yeah happy birthday Chris
mold off so John he yeah him and I were
in high school together and then we
actually went to Community College
together and then college together and
then we got married and done the baby
yeah so yeah we started the company and
we just started doing like weird quick
blogs where the post doodles and just
like weird internet things we found food
share means before means really super
dank like when there's regular they
weren't dank medium just me haha and
then we uh yeah and we were both graphic
design majors digital media so from
there kind of just spurred into this
thing where I was like yeah I look cool
like on clothing and then we sent a few
beanies to some friends we sold a few
and then became like this thing that now
is like it's really grown yeah like like
it's taken off yeah we've every 50 all
50 states we've sold - that's crazy like
40 to 50 countries Guam turkey Turkey
you have the power of the internet on
your Saudi Arabia so yeah it's all on
lines we've spent zero dollars in
advertising Wow Wow um but it's really
exciting because the actually the other
day we went to a Tim and Eric book
signing
yeah they're great and we're over in
line like there's a kid like you know 10
15 people behind us rocking a maroon
need to be that kind of completely
unplanned I was like this moment been
waiting for for like two years
did you find the actual I did my ran up
I rehabbed to him and I find it and I
was like hey and now I look back at it
and I'm like okay it's blurry as hell
it's so no oh no it's like our solid
vial yeah this looks like it was the
moment yeah it was the moment statement
also excited that's funny so genuine
vine yeah
be cool though like the coolest thing in
the world yeah he was like yeah you're
that guy does only get a lot bad guy
you're that guy I'll get like hey are
you from vine like yeah I was born
they're born it's been great
no I I get I'll get like recognized like
on the train or like walking or I'll get
people tweeting at me yeah so you guys
in the airport yeah yeah so high it was
good like yeah yeah I know right yeah
they tell you in hindsight yeah or
they'll take a picture of you walking
though this you don't look good that's
always the weirdness I think when ya see
a picture of you from like weird angles
remember Luna Park come say hi oh yeah I
got those yeah we both got about
Instagram like they tagged us in they're
like taking a picture of themselves like
in it and I said you could have said hi
to like we didn't want to bother you I'm
like but you were they were walking with
us the whole day there next one so
there's the hi I was like I don't wanna
bother me they'll say just what see if
I'd be buying it over it's not bothering
at all this time paper to be regular
that's really funny be regular yeah I
think it's cool that you guys came up
with his name neat dude and largely the
brand has kind of taken off because of
those two words like it's not like you
may need to then it's like oh we
expanded on this and that like every
piece of merchandise you sell kind of
revolve around many dude which is really
cool and like you obviously have some
insane graphic designs because I always
tell you that yeah like you have really
cool it's ah [ __ ] yeah a lot of that is
John Johnson man he'll uh he'll tweet
snake and I snakes the other guy um you
messed make and so he'll tweet though
like a text us like an idea Becky I'm
working on this and then we'll give him
a little pointers like I'd be cool in
there and then like he should throw this
on a black shirt like that's dealt let's
order it was it right away
that's see that's the team you got
that's awesome the shirts were sure they
were wearing now the dad did that his
[ __ ] one guy say that yeah cool what
yeah um that shirt was a no so that was
my design and like my idea like yeah
that'd be cool this on a shirt and then
John
tweaked it a little bit like a smoke
going through the date that was his idea
you touch on the defining a little
little rough textures you can see on
those metal my idea yeah yeah it was
like it was like a nice little
collaboration back and forth again a
product that came out of it it's really
it's beautiful and dad as [ __ ] yeah
we're thing about doing Mama's [ __ ]
we're not sure yet pretty nice thing let
us know in the comments I'm sure you
guys have already heard of me too and
literally is everywhere especially
online like every other vine you watch
there's somewhere there's nitu that's
crazy yeah that's also the culture of
vine as well is that you guys really
much like the YouTube community do a
good job supporting each other yeah yeah
everyone's so supportive if someone has
a Kickstarter where they're like hey
mm-hmm I'm trying to do this but
majority people will support it and let
post about it not expect anything in
return because you know it's just like
you don't want to tell any selfish yeah
yeah yeah no that's really cool though
yeah and you see it too yeah people you
collab with anytime they're up to
something you're always behind them on
whatever it is but it's it's cool to see
for sure mm-hmm
and then I feel like a lot of times
you'll like I'll go out and oh don't go
my way well if I season that's really
funny I'll refine it and be like do that
that was fine just get some more honest
on good job versus like doing it with
other people just to you know do it and
then hello people see it yeah another
share some that's actually fine like
organically yeah yeah that's a we've met
you mentioned like the likes thing Jenna
does look through people she thought
finds funny on lines likes and you will
give them love all the time just because
they're funny oh yeah
I can't help it yeah you don't mean yeah
it's the most pure form of like oh this
is funny to me I'm gonna hit right
especially when you're being like a
spectator of the internet like maybe I'm
not making a vine or YouTube video or
anything I'm not creating anything I'm a
spectator like anybody else so if I
think it's [ __ ] funny I'm gonna
comment on I like it yeah I can do
whatever I want okay I will show all of
my friends until they tell me to leave
the room being obnoxious really it
matters what did you guys see this one
big Jenna's not fine no you like show me
a vine right you know like this funny
vine is so hilarious you need to watch
it as a show it to me and I'll watch it
like huh that's funny
and then she'll like keep it playing and
I'm like I saw it
and she has to watch like three or four
loops before she like fully just like
Beatrice met you how many times did so
many keep like pressing it to me
actually stop on the regular how many
times 17 27 26
17:38 was it ever 17 that's the Saran
number I came up with in my head thanks
26 26 measured I guess at that point all
the time where it stops the big and a
half to live it I've never ever even a
glance around made an entire video of me
crying laughing at that one that was
before they did that I was at four if I
did that I sit there and I like I was a
hilarious all phases of like me crying
laughing it's mine I can't help it okay
that's a good thing my makeup everywhere
everywhere oh no like once in a while I
get like a Julian or a general like I'm
just like okay all the times that people
will like watch that word of it when you
get the light you're like that like is
good yeah cuz a lot of people like that
yeah so it's also cool because you know
they're watching like live like up they
just they literally just watch that yes
it's cool it's a cool thing that is true
it's super instant it's so much feedback
yeah yeah yeah mind you youtube is still
on the 301 plus tree yeah that's been
like that for years I don't I really I
couldn't tell you why it's like now but
it's sort of weird you can even upload a
video but it'll be 301 plus views for
like hours like free arts huh they're
like 8,000 likes so I can find update
instantly and YouTube is still like
three Olympics it's a good question you
do a lot more users I think a lot more
users yeah so what isn't it well they do
they have that process where they have
to make sure that nothing is copy
written or like age-restricted
so they're like pausing it sort of
they're really still counting they're
just not showing you yeah now I'm doing
about it might go through that little
discretionary period or do I really have
to make sure it like adheres to the
community guidelines you [ __ ] yes making
a coastal view yeah hey yeah so you guys
make vines like um individually also
together is cool and you guys are like a
public thing you're like anti yeah we're
dating no yes
mention it but yes your data you guys
like your like publicly like a couple
he's interesting because we deal with
that too
yeah yeah how do you find that in terms
of like putting binds out and like being
on the internet all the time even also
being part of this other thing
awesome work yeah and you guys are
always so super like normal and natural
and yes it so it's never like hey this
is my boyfriend this is everybody's just
like you're always together and yeah
soon
I don't like when people are like overly
like Miami
yeah we don't really do any like - super
um like tease you out there you scared
the [ __ ] out right yeah that's all
that's another thing you do yeah I love
that
yeah slow down though so that's did you
scare once you think like probably like
sneeze one thing I start hanging out
with her and was just in she was getting
scared of the dumbest things I'll like
sneeze at you like no well I would like
open a door to them like I like why what
why is there anything why are you so
then in the car one day I'm just like
hmm I'm just gonna scream and see what
happens and I just did I filmed it and
she like reaction was so funny
alright I'm just going to do this a lot
don't make a compilation just post on
YouTube and then yeah yeah I started
stop doing a little bit because she now
expects it and it's also have two other
other people do your bidding like yeah
like Jenna did Julia laughs I did it
oh yeah um yeah I also don't want to
like give her like health problems
thank you no thumbs not very pleased
yeah so this is the Chris Mel burger
face yeah super dead eyes yeah just like
hate games dead inside I think to think
about like the worst thing oh my god
you let you start at that hashtag I just
hashtag it once I because like I didn't
know what else to call it
yeah I was like and then like panetta
stuff like is now people like this I saw
like retweet or Dino people are saying
it and doing it so like some people
tagged me and Instagram picture of them
doing it and not you in and also so
we're not in it it's just them people
don't even know some people don't know
who I am they're just like I sleep
remark ever made of like word Chris
Arnold um that's really funny yeah they
were hanging out with Matt King today
and he is like the master of faces he
makes some you know I can yes yeah he
makes really awesome faces and like
known for his face and like when he was
doing the crystal on her face I guess
that's what we're calling it it was just
kind of like it was fine to see him do
it because he has so many different ones
and see him with dead eyes was just like
whoa he ever like makes it huge yeah
yeah there's cool yeah that's me that
he's cool like that melted the Chris
Marburger face thank you so much oh
there's teeth one then there's this one
that's the one that like the dead inside
yes
after the dead inside this one you so
you have like vines go viral
kind of like sort of all the time now
I'm dancing around laughing yeah that's
pretty good what we what do we say viral
what is that like over you tell me so
like what's your normal like is you
gonna stream out but usual doesn't mean
the same thing anymore no it doesn't it
does in terms of vine I feel like you
you have a vine on the popular page of
vine regularly which is when you make
like the Apple watch Ryan that one yeah
that one yeah reddit you posted it yeah
front page right so I'm I'm writing and
I'm like Chris I'm like this is Chris
fight and I go through the constantly
wait
Opie is Chris like what device you are
god yeah yeah yeah I used to been I read
it for like four years and I was just
like yeah think four years and I used to
just post like I would make like rage
comics or like old school like little
poster be like oh this make this we
flying pics or this might be a funny
thing yeah a little shower thought here
and there but now it's like oh we just
put my vines in here maybe
what happened I've had if that's how
that the scare cams got big sigh posted
on the YouTube haiku section like under
30 second videos got it
parents Nelly number five all-time on
their wow that's awesome is really cool
I love that you like use that platform
no one thinks to do that kind of stuff
could there very is very hard to doubt
because you got vine which is like young
a lot of young girls yeah and then you
got read it which is like a lot of like
20 or 30 year old dudes in baseball and
another interesting thing is I mean vine
gets a bad rap sometimes like certain
people online give it that bad rap I
think it's fair to say and I think a
place like reddit like you'll go on and
a shitty like really popular but kind of
shitty vinyl be posted and it'll somehow
get pushed to the top and all the
comments be like this is why we hate
vine or something like that so it's like
for you to put lines on the platform and
have them be well-received is it says
something about you don't know why it's
there but that's cool ya know it helps
ya get you some money yeah alright
enough about you yeah the saga is talked
about every statement like Shane you do
photography right and addition here what
kind of photographer you do um I feel
like more like surreal setup stuff I
don't know I actually have a show in LA
in November so I have to get ready for
that okay see you they don't have actor
I don't even know home oh yeah it's good
because I did it was the last year or
two years ago and I had a like frame
everything and then sent in the mail Wow
and then whatever they whatever I didn't
sell it got sent back so that's great so
it looks like you have a show of all
your work and it's just like oh I wish I
could go how do you arrange it out of
thing I have just give us some and I
like hope for the best of it up nice
that's really cool and then I was like
can you send pictures live wall so I
could see it looks like but on this
ember
yeah remember and you're not gonna be
here nah cool periscope for perfect an
entire thing bag but like yeah
there you go that's getting it good then
and go then you posted a picture of the
street vine in Hollywood the other day
hi my name is nacho oh yeah why Street
huh Hollywood mine yeah like I think we
did last time was cool because it was a
good it's like a certain theme yeah so
she took all these awesome pictures yeah
I don't even know what to do now
like I'm so do you like go out into the
world and find like I don't know how
this break your style
usually like like recently what I've
been doing or what I have done is like I
just glue stuff my face or like put like
a bug of my mouth that's right okay
that's right I've seen some of those
pictures I feel like eyeballs Jules what
camera do you use
I have a Canon 7d mmm last what glass I
have so many so many got so my glass
sunglasses so much glass much glass very
well no I have a lot even like it
doesn't assure you it's like each one
for a different
yeah probably down yeah science now
that's really cool she actually directed
a video Vitas record her did you the
cast everyone oh yeah it up my
documentary she's a documentary on toxic
taxidermy my friend who's attacked these
records dr. Mary yeah I'd like to
everything heal me yeah are you doing I
just like stood there that's one so
they're gonna be fine they're working on
my youtube but is my friend Katie and
she's awesome she travels all over the
country and only teaches classes of
taxidermy stuff to like people Wow like
people have never done it before
so yukl you've studied like taxidermy
and I actually haven't seen you guys
know from what I just yeah I mean I just
know from my visa but like she's really
cool and she does like birds she'll have
a pigeon clash with guinea pigs oh my
gosh that's really genius I'm donated
from like hunters or whatever people are
just gonna throw them out right and she
just does it for the class you pay for
you know whatever happens like six hours
and we sat in I want
our class tonight I shot a whole
documentary on her and we doing stuff
yet it's on your YouTube channel
yeah I won't tell us your YouTube
channel we can link it below willing all
the stuff for whatever YouTube check
it's just I think it's just YouTube /
and odd is it on Vimeo no youtube is on
YouTube yeah yeah and should channel my
inner Norman Bates I know
yeah Norman Bates you got Terry's dogs
yeah it's crazy here like an owl mine
episode I was like that's so illegal but
so beautiful like yeah birds are like
that's like that whole show it's so
illegal but so beautiful baby yeah
isn't she staying in Los Angeles that's
a senior's Anderson
I don't even know she's all over yes I
guess she was teaching yes she was doing
like a one-month thing yeah like staying
air and like working at the Los Angeles
something news I am yeah the school
museum man how do you guys say that word
Museum we don't say it's out there Music
Museum where's the ozium Museum museum
it's a weird work soda water museum
seltzer water no soda wine salsa water
people comment below comment blogs it's
hurt herself subscribe you say crayon
crayon crayon crayon crayon crayon
crayon
I love the it's great ro n okay watch
this alumni alumni no no no there's no
it's just alumni alumni whisper
challenge
oh man speech chairman Oh mommy
I'm not gonna speak shimmer no you want
to like feel like throwing up but also
laugh really hard because that's what it
does okay it repeats your own voice at a
slower rate back to you and your
earphones is talking so it's like you're
hearing yourself slower that's hard it's
very tricky how do you like it so you
put headphones on yeah you run the app
on your phone sure and start jamming
speech so don't start say memorization I
really hate Chris because I'll be trying
to like keep up with my slow voice yeah
tricks you might your ma yeah you can't
control I mean you can if you try really
hard I think I've seen people like that
a couple of don't beat it yeah you know
shobha try really hard you can you gotta
give in something a good way to like bug
out you try the inception app like the
old the one that was like released when
I came out no what is it
so you plug it in and there's different
like rooms or areas you can go like
different options and select ones like
it kind of alters your surroundings and
you have like headphones on you be like
hello hello I'm big it changes its grace
it's so doable is using the background
I'll do when I used to block commute to
work in the city how could walk around
like I wasn't and like if you saw if you
start moving faster it like picks up the
speed so you actually feel like you're
like getting changes there's like a
legit oh it's also you're in a movie oh
my god it's amazing link below it's so
it's called the inception the inception
app is the inception ah yeah and well I
know what I'm doing tonight yeah you
could if you get drunk and do it it's
also really fun
that sounds horrifying yeah a scam like
that's a terrifying night like get drunk
do the inception I have to the speed
camera challenge do it the challenge
dynamesh mulch and implode is that fun
it all comes back to glue yeah
everything little did she do that
picture of Kermit as glue no that's a
terrifying picture son you guys it's a
drawing of an edit that someone made
it's a exactly it's a drawing of an
edited so foreign that's the internet so
drivin in it and trying oven at 7:00
that's really funny
thanks for lo face nice terrifying did
Elmer's pay for that
no that's why the eyes are covering ours
nice I'm not that cool guys he hasn't a
great wall over here yeah there's some
pretty sunny yeah we moved the podcast
this way because the picture was all
like so it was so colorful and bright
behind a set distorted the color took
away from us
it's equation so we might go back to
that side if we have a green screen
remember but for an hour this yeah so
you guys are in here in what 10 7 moment
you don't know you might be here for
like 3 months I don't know so what are
you doing for the rest your stay so
you're working it your birthday's yeah
where is my birthday yes and we're well
don't tell people my age I'm scam 25
half the quarter quarter quarter century
I made the face back um good night and I
was like oh he's turning a half a
century old like are you Benjamin bunny
oh my oh yeah that's uh
so you Vernon 50th birthday in LA
turning half a half a century yes
quarter so we're gonna have some friends
some cocktails some beer cocktails
that's not the crime Marv's some see me
a little more room
oh I've literally never even heard that
kind of care mark oh um your bartender
you were bartender I was about Tina time
at her she was bartending too we poke
for attention
he hasn't booked bartenders he got a
tended bar we tended bar you also tend
bar now there's like a flex rating
reflects mmm peace by Chris longer
imagine imagine a bench in healing I
feel
you're my spotter like cuz you're dead
inside you have no distance or pain or
just no the UFC fighter got in Nelson
Gunnar Nelson if he's an isolated face
it would be this that's a great exactly
this guy is an Icelandic fighter he is
zero expression he just looks like this
every second you see him he looks like
he just got out of fighting while he's
fight and he's an incredible fighter so
he'll win a giant fight and he'll just
walk around the Kingsley yeah okay
oh you're gonna be a dad oh yeah we
should yeah you know there's like a
chart where it's like excited sad hungry
it's all the same thing that's what you
got to do for you and then Elwha you see
the one where's like uh when you when
you type column FAO like what you expect
like did reality yeah yeah yeah just
like nothing the sound I make when I say
ah yeah I know it um it's [ __ ] up Oh
little bear pops on your nose yeah yeah
and you're like it's what happens every
time you go snorts Arab that's an lol
yeah like visa lol means like sit around
and cry on the couch for like 12 hours
until everyone's asked you to stop
simply stop Jonathan won't have a seat
right over here right over here
intervention series um well and you also
have your other job where you work at
inbox messenger it's in New York yes I
was an app yeah so I actually got that
job too because of I'm uh-huh and uh oh
wait hey I start over there good I start
there I started actually working with
him in August I would come in once a
week and we make a vine and I was there
it was kind of like hey guys thank you
see you later
hey guys thank you see later and then we
kind of had like that we all bonded very
well we all have to wear on the same
page and then I was like oh hey you
wanna work here I was like okay so they
gave me a role on the the director of
social media now now I'm doing social
media but I'm also doing a lot of
internal stuff marketing
yeah um influencer relationships we went
to actually plan the whole trip and did
like all this stuff and it was like
crazy like pretty much got my whole
company to go to playlist live in
Orlando we had our own booth and like I
flew out six different influencers to
this event Wow
and it was like a lot of their first
times like experiment Chris was there
Chris there's his first time like
meeting people on like salesmen he was
like blowing up and everyone was like he
was like it was like literally was
scoring a Beatle
we had a high head we were bringing into
the lobby the girls were like ah I try
to grab in all the closets crews we're
just trying to get coming autographs
later oh yeah there's a crash mat King
Toby Stephens Shan me J Cyrus who you
guys had on the show that's right well I
think beyond we all got a trip to yeah
anyone else
no no hopefully that's cool that you
were like in charge of yeah I was like
the dad it was so strange you can really
come out to dad ah yeah they'd come to
me and be like what sould be like okay
well you guys have your meetup schedule
at this time so [ __ ] sick though yeah
well you were a creator we can also like
ready to show yeah that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah so in box we did that and then we
we have been doing a lot of like
internal work now we're really kicking
ass on the app and it's actually blowing
up in Mexico and Brazil and a lot of
like South American countries Nicaragua
huh yeah we had a story written about us
in the Mexico blog forgave those call
but is this great website but yeah it's
cool so we were actually talking to some
Mexican Viner influencers to help
promote it because that's like the
audience ever trying like that's been
yeah that's really cool
but yeah if you want to message me on
inbox my username is at CM I have this
that's the cool user man hey I have that
finger as many yeah Kendall yeah and you
could the cool thing is you can draw
yeah inbox is cool there's a bunch of
cool features you guys check it out link
below it's a messaging app but it goes
way past just typing messages yeah it's
crossing clean yeah really cool very
minimalistic it's cool because you don't
feel like give people your actual phone
number yeah and you can unsend text
yeah scandalous so do you sound like a
really cool pic and you wanted Sam send
it
that's my cool pic yeah you can have
that name here ya little bog glad to see
ya
yeah that's big cool I like that awesome
yep and I think hmmm what you guys have
anything else do you want to like
promote really yes all your stuff yeah
yeah well obviously linked accounts will
link your photography and your
documentary as well yeah and your to
yourself need to be honest you know yeah
Kris Jenner YouTube channel no they yeah
oh you you each have one yeah I too have
a tube some use all funnier than Susumu
so we have our cam something you saw my
vlog is that I hear chats my channel
okay for some reason ours it was really
- there was a chance not yet you got the
HIV on Channel yeah I mean like rotate
vlogs how do you do it like here and
there gotta go go our hike the other day
that was on Krista channel yeah yeah I
knew Chris was really cool so you guys
sounds like it's like a tower yeah then
I use a go process there we go propel we
go the whole thing go guys you go go go
boys go Tim go - voice doesn't do it for
me oh look it's like it does for some
people it's a moist moist
niced alumni I'm dead and summon a lemon
are aluminum I let me ship it in cuz I'm
good yeah do you have anything else like
you want to tell people to go to and
check it out
besides the try think of other things I
mean we tweet gram yeah call yourself
thank you guys so much for come on that
was fun here what's okay I could like
couldn't even no sarcasm on time
you guys are you guys are getting your
money you get your money's not even
response on the show your abs your on
carry on YouTube free on iTunes free on
some Club yes right we are South on now
you're on all the stuff we're on the
five final Ron sounds odd nine thank you
guys for watching and make sure to check
out all their stuff below they you guys
do awesome stuff so keep your vision
yeah we're real life friends were
excited we're friends IRL so we're gonna
do our best now to delay them from ever
buying a flight back to home so they can
just stay here forever
kidnapping yeah you guys for watching
and thanks again for coming see you guys
next week on down is really podcast yeah
it's hot now